lasst mich sagen jetzt muss eigentlich
thomas hayo leute was er zieht ist ein
zusammenschnitt aus sieben einzelnen mal
wo ich liebe getränk gibt ist oder
einfach aufs heftigste gepiesackt
hartplätze genau ich meinen kopf thomas
spielt sofort nein
das spiel doch die wir hier keiner sehen
das tat kurz weg so warum ich jetzt ist
es mit thomas knapp zehn minuten zwei
gestellt werden kann verstehst du es
nicht also ich habe bis heute trainiert
sie haben das über offenbar dass der
schreibende jung ist fiel zuletzt jeder
denkt viel zu viel nach es war einfach
nur machen weil das problem war dass ich
wäre es gut wir machen jetzt ein richtig
schön dass wir mal eine entschädigung im
leben von thomas durch guten schnitt und
postproduktion rede ist kommt er
verbessern mit witzigen effekten sein
gesicht wird schwerer hin scheint noch
nicht lange bis es wirklich leute thomas
machst du was machst du das siehst du
witze
du hast ihn halt jetzt ein riesiges
riesige server für den tollen street
ihren der kleine rechnung zugeschnitten
hast da kann man fast schon sagen das
ist echt scheiße gelaufen
deshalb soll ja eigentlich schon dass
ich glaube wenn man sich das ganze mal
anschaut kann man nicht wissen was soll
das alles dinge junge vielleicht bereust
du ihn eingestellt zu haben
[Musik]
auch damit auch damit hatte ich gesagt
habe ich richtig gut gesagt altermatt
respekt wo ist mein pulitzer preis ist
so maßmann polizei kreist ich hasse den
jungs haben mich jedoch ziehen kann wenn
so was jetzt klaus werden die leute
richtig wir können michael moore ein
aberglaube thomas kuhles du die weiten
pass eigentlich heute irgendwie das ist
ja erst meldete du hast einfach genau an
der stelle auch im neuen mitarbeiter
unserer whiteboard was wir schon länger
nicht benutzt habe sich auch noch die
letzten reste verlust sagt nicht dass du
schon wieder mit dem haus wieder mit cd
markt darauf gemalt man jetzt können wir
jetzt weg werfen wollte und dass zweifel
dass krieger darunter der bekannte ich
auf andere art und weise verletzten
thomas ist der wahre hast du das selber
genau das stimmt nicht wo man das nicht
der wahre star des kanals ihr habt mich
abonniert und thomas ist etwas negatives
passiert etwas krank widerliches
nein denn ein produkt ist nicht passiert
thomas alles in ordnung
ja weil ich war richtig gebacken bekommt
es im schnitt so unterhaltsam zu
gestalten dass ich mehr zehn minuten
ergibt meine freunde
thomas ja das video ist jetzt elf
minuten 38 29 euro was können wir daraus
machen müssen doch zwölf minuten hallo
hallo telefon witze immer wieder
einbringen
ja der witz kader ist jetzt plötzlich
der ton aus wie konnte das denn
passieren
ich hab vergessen das mikro anzuschalten
aber er sagt reh wie nichts dabei alles
easy ich weiß noch genauestens was er
gesagt hat und außerdem ist meine stimme
64 wir sind jetzt im neuen büro unter
dient ist auch mit am start
hallo kranker typ young boys was geht
hier haben wir licht aber bevor ich es
vergesse dass herr schenke ich thomas
genauso wie meinauto.de 856 jets
mindestens jetzt erst mal am finger
lecken
lecker finger ganz kurz das mikrofon ist
aus oder macht muss an
warum bisschen roswitha schneider das
ist ein friedvolles tschechen tomas noch
unter malta ist der video steht nicht ob
du mit anfassen kannst
das ist ein leben alter weißt du bist
katar sitzt hier trotzdem frist chips
bin ich dein katar was denn es ist mein
büro kommt es hier konnten videos an und
spielt geht her und ist chips ja und
trinkt tee abgesagt locker leben hat es
nicht mal was bezahlt ja schon ich
arbeite hat alles klar leute ich suche
wird neue angestellte leute mit einem 17
bis 180 mm objektiv ganz nett auf jeden
fall ist glaube ich das optimalste hier
ist ein allrounder foto und video
objektiv kann man ganz gut nutzen macht
auf jeden fall eine menge spaß zu
schneiden oder thomas super perfekt gut
hier wieder eine woche lang fort nicht
gespielt und man ist direkt wieder als
würde man das spiel zum ersten mal
spielt es tut einfach nur weh aber mein
herz mein gedanke thomas danke für deine
rege beteiligung in diesem video
normalen kannst du auch nichts zu essen
immer im video
das gibt dann hier so unschön abdruck
nicht
ich weiß nicht aber das sehen kann laut
man sieht das ganz gut gerade thomas hat
uns gemacht ich bin mal gespannt ich
kenne jetzt einen gips und katja ja
genau du weißt warum ich hier bin
siehst du diese schläger ich will nicht
nur ein gangster sondern ich will oben
ist der zauber los nimbus 2000
nein nein warum alter wieso jedes mal
habe ich es verdammt der bild von katja
als thumbnail aber es klappt doch jedes
mal weil es immer 600.000 autos machen
danke dafür thomas die mitarbeit
und ich habe all das spielt seinen
kindern gespendet warum hast du das
gemacht damit es dir doch nicht so
langweilig wird das klingt ja fast so
wie ein erlebnis aus thomas kleiner
vergangenheit wirken jetzt du musst
eigentlich fährt sie gar nicht im gold
cup um thomas muster und ich hake thomas
kannst du mir so ich kann mich dabei
fühle
doch thomas 19 einfach nur toll und der
beste hat eine welt was ist das tor
du kannst nicht die ganze zeit mir
selber schauen bringen
funktional der tollste netteste mensch
und der besten spielerinnen der welt
es ist so schrecklich ich brauche 90 das
ist nicht mit deinem blog auf die thomas
wir machen ihren professionellen tester
hallo nicht ist was ich jetzt mal wieder
haben oder ja hier wieder das ist ein
missbrauch nicht möglich ich helfe dir
plötzlich jeden schlagen kann
doch ich will sehen nur den abstand noch
weiter
ja das ist der abspann hallo live gold
in loch wenn es nicht leute wenn meine
videos so großes cracks und dass man
nicht auf und kann sie zu gucken und das
design was meiner sicht das ist aus
meiner sicht ja thomas du lebst sich
nach der art von joko jetzt das wort als
morgen jetzt kannst du einfach dann
keine ahnung ob überhaupt alles was wir
brauchen was wir brauchen eine folie
junge du bist echt nicht hier hätte ich
mir auf jeden fall nicht bei thomas am
kanal vorbei weil da gibt es nichts
nennenswertes zu sehen den letzten tagen
schaut auf jeden fall muss am kanal
vorbei weil er gibt es mehr dazu sehen
den letzten tagen
wieso hab ich was ich habe den finger zu
schneiden thomas wäre würde ich auf den
bus unser ganzes wasser thomas wilde
flinner sitzung finde ich einfach so
viel alkohol nicht mehr gehört
ich hab ein problem da wir haben voll
geplant so ich muss nicht so oft langen
werde ich das geschnitten habe dann fand
ich jetzt von lustigen momente dabei ich
dachte ich mach mal so ein kleines best
of damit diese ganzen kleinen
sticheleien nicht in vergessenheit
geraten und ich weiß dass viele von euch
lust haben schnitt und visual effects
diese ganze film ag zu lernen deswegen
bringe ich ihnen ungefähr einer woche
kurse raus also aber nicht mal auf
instagram denn da halte ich euch auf dem
laufenden und wenn ihr lust hat mich auf
diese reise zu begleiten
lasst mir gerne abo dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder mal gut
[Musik]